hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to muddy Heights - now yes
this is as equal to a poop game
literally just a poop game game about
poop anyway so this came out a while ago
and I meant to play before and
apparently there's three levels of which
you can get a star golden for pooping on
everybody's dreams but I don't know well
to do that just yet so we're gonna find
out probably very similar to the first
and what you're standing on a rooftop
looking down and everyone why is
everyone wearing a poop shirt what is it
about this town and poop why does our
own white poop so much I mean I'm gonna
be assuming that they would be eating
poop except I know that they're just
gonna poop out the poop anyway oh look
at you you look so nice and not very
stressed right now but you're gonna be
very stressed very soon three more lives
I don't have the money for that
so let's go poop whoa Oh God okay so how
does he whoa do I have control of this
not quite okay little bouncy on this
poop sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
still going Headly Oh God town Cobb oh
yeah I did my goal I don't know why I'm
still able to control this poop what
kind of demon did I eat that I was able
to actually have manual control over
where my poop goes and the kind of [ __ ]
that it does to devastate the village so
I got one moneys I don't know how to do
the monies so longer poop duration
bigger splatters double jump faster
speed higher jump explode with F longer
combo time all right let's do that
everyone knows that corn is not
digestible so that it needs to some
[ __ ] about poop boink
Oh No the devastation the poop is
station the dev app option I don't know
husky Oh going home
there's a truck dedicated to poop
everybody's license plate is poop why it
doesn't make any goddamn sense excuse me
were you eating this I have no idea
let's pry some secrets that I really
should know about Oh find a secret music
mishap I don't know how to do that
what did I did okay bubblegum
double-jump
yeah I'll go for that let's go okay so I
need to ruin five dinners poink oh no
whoop ruined dinner ruin this dinner
ruin that dinner whoop ruin this dinner
ruin that dinner okay I gotta go to the
other side I'll ruin these dinners yeah
we did that okay that's a thing
hey where are you going everybody all
right I think we need three more lives
because otherwise what are we gonna be
able to do about all this I'm not gonna
be able to do everything I don't know
where all the secrets are how would I
know I don't want to play this game I
don't want to have like encyclopédie
attic knowledge of this that just seems
like a horrible way to go no pun
intended
it's gotta be a secret back here or
something ah there we are
oh [ __ ]
literally Isis somewhere there's more
toilet papers but I don't know where
hydro poof bombs away fertilizer all
these things do not understand sorry
[Music]
well I thought that was gonna be it
[Music]
whoa [ __ ] sorry whoa geez okay
didn't mean to do that sorry everybody
Sorry Sorry does markable are coming
through market 'red oh so where are
these other toilet-paperers probably one
is nearer side new hey bird ah I got you
birdy so where are these things
well I got one poop left and I have no
idea what I'm supposed to be doing I
don't know where the other TP is oh it's
up there how is get up there how in the
frickin frak do you think I'm gonna get
up there goddamn it level complete but I
didn't do everything that I meant to do
might as well go to the next level
because I got nothing else better to do
about this then take a [ __ ] on the world
that I hate Harry on air can go freak
himself I see a toilet paper I see it
scouting me all right I know where all
the toilet paper are now last handy
let's do that
a little wimpy one I [ __ ] oh come on
with the [ __ ] hello swimming pool
uh-huh whoa
burning rubber all righty then okay so I
need to be the DJ which I imagine
there's someone doing music over oh yes
of course of course sorry excuse me
sorry
I hope ya get the music on get the
shitty shitty club music wow lady hey
how you doing
yeah sorry she fell for me hi well I'm
really glad that this town is very
confident with their bodies I am very
excited that sounded weird I'm not
excited I'm proud I gotta get these
toilet papers I can get them I know
where they all are
second one boink yeah there we go
fast one I know I'm great whoop hip okay
I can get that other one sorry
oh god I'm so sorry oh I'm sorry oh you
don't want to take poop as a pre-workout
that's actually a horrible idea
whoa bouncy no ice okay I can get this
last one not sure if I can get it in
time though huh [ __ ] god dammit ah [ __ ]
lagging get the other one and I can get
another score at the same time husky
[ __ ] okay I can make it from here oh
[ __ ]
come on oh no no no no oh god I can make
it oh jeez oh [ __ ] no no no
affect me [ __ ] damn it there we go
that's what I was looking for some
elevation on me there we go
girls got the toilet paper that's
another dollar that's another dollar in
the bank ow
sorry sorry I got it cause of panic real
quick [ __ ] okay they should slip a lot
of them should slip they should slip
keep the combo up yeah yeah yes okay so
that's good that increase my score quite
a bit so I got three more to make
another big score explode with F sounds
bad but I'm not trying I want to see the
[ __ ] Splosion going on here at the beach
all right so I got to get 40,000 it's
the only way so my intention is to make
everybody panic and then slip up the
roadways so much that no one could
possibly get away and then blast off and
explode oh god I might not make it
oh [ __ ] might not make God better better
better better boom go go go go go yeah
yeah yeah something for the pen falling
down it's a slip in [ __ ] slip and fall
yeah no yes okay so I got all of them I
did it yeah go me I didn't think I was
gonna I guess this is all just for shits
and giggles now I don't actually need to
worry about any of it right the pool I'm
gonna go in the ring ah [ __ ] that's
probably a secret blink yep hole-in-one
I knew it
any other secrets that are obvious no
sorry everybody had to splode
[Music]
this okay that should be it
okay finish I'm all done with my poopy
on that level there's only one more
level to go to and I can't imagine is
gonna be much different but hey it's an
adventure ain't it oh boy a roller
coaster park on the pier this will be
fantastic I'm gonna make my poop go up
on the drop tower because apparently
there's a teepee up there I'm just
surveying the scene studying the level
you dance lady man you dance I only got
two of them revenge I'm not getting
revenge I don't want revenge here you
punk
okay yes yes please sorry sorry god damn
it don't get don't get caught on that
there stupid piece of poop panic panic
panic in the streets oh [ __ ] okay so far
so goo hi kid run away or derail the
coaster well that's gonna take some
timing what oh [ __ ] god damn it I was so
close dirty job oh god I'm sorry I
didn't really want to touch that fish
suit with my poop but life is that way
oh yeah
do you real the coast you got that okay
that's gonna be money in the blow upma
getting I'm sorry oh god I killed me oh
geez possible oh damn it I was supposed
to go for the teepee god damn and I'm
not gonna make it oh [ __ ]
god damn it give me that double jump god
damn it huh
albatross I bet if I hit one of those
who'd be very beneficial to me but I
don't have that luxury just yet oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] god damn [ __ ] you oh yeah you
want to get away from me how about this
accuracy
oh [ __ ] you got that don't know where
the other ones are but I got that one
alright there's my last try if I don't
get a 20 combo or a high score I'm
[ __ ]
dammit I was gonna hit a bird well
that's gonna be something hopefully that
gives me some goddamn score
[Music]
okay that should do it that should do it
that should do that should do it
maybe oh come on get the goddamn it the
car the combo is right there [ __ ] me
alright that's it I'm a failure I'm bad
at the poop game I'm all done here I got
one not so that is muddy Heights - now I
didn't get completionist on any of that
but if you total that up I'm over a
hundred percent I'm like a 5.2 on the
GPA scale I'm doing great
even though it's a game about poop so
anyway that's all I'm gonna play now you
can find this game on Steam the only
thing is the first game was free this
game cost three bucks so play it if you
want you may be able to complete it but
then again it's a game about poop how
much the honor can that bring you so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you
[Music]